we unleashed something powerful we have
to stop her if you want to do something
right you make a list - we got to fight
ghost 3 we're gonna track down ghost
that seems like she'd be part of two to
a
watch this
[Music]
Oh also we have to save the world that's
major we can't forget that hey everybody
its charlie we got new a man and the
wasp footage to break down there's a
little infinity war Easter Egg in there
that you may remember from the end of
that movie that I'll talk about but they
give us a better idea for what the
actual plot of the film is and what
exactly is going on with the ghost
character who we know is the big bad of
the film but I think this trailer gives
you an idea for what her arc is because
sunny Burge is also one of the other
Justin Hammer type characters in the
film so if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the marbled videos I'm still doing
that infinity war DVD giveaway all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this - so the big thing in this is
they let you know that they caused a
really big problem we unleashed
something terrible meaning that they
probably accidentally create the ghost
while she's in the middle of a heist so
if you don't know who the ghost is it's
basically this corporate saboteur that
has a really cool tech in the comics
that's basically the whole pitch because
they had pitched this movie initially as
them going into the quantum realm to
save Janet Van Dyne x' wasp who got lost
there so long ago it sounds like what
might be going on is they're just doing
that while they're under house arrest
like they find out some secret about the
quantum realm oh my god like you see the
reaction on their faces here this might
be when they learn about Janet Van Dyne
being alive inside the quantum realm so
they freaked out but you also have this
sort of side plot with the sunny burch
character who seems like he's trying to
steal Pym tech like everybody wants
their hands on Pym tech that was the
whole big Hydra thing during the
original ant-man movie if you don't know
who he is that's Walton Goggins he's
been in a whole bunch of stuff he called
his character more of a small-time
criminal but it sounds like the films
using him is more of a Justin Hammer
type even though it's a bit of a
misdirect because the ghost is going to
become the real villain so when you see
ant-man turn into giant man and chase
after him in that funny car chase like
he has PIMs building in his lap there
like he's just stolen it regardless of
where this is happening during the movie
it sounds like he hires the ghost this
really awesome corporate saboteur to
steal Pym tech for him in a while she's
doing that there's an accident involving
the quantum realm that gives her her
powers and the ability to phase they
make it seem like her powers are bigger
than that because
see this building explode after they say
they unleashed something terrible but I
think that's just part of the accident
that gives her her powers her big thing
as the trailer explains is just phasing
through anything
so when ant-man says the world is in
danger I think there are a couple of
things going on there so obviously this
is happening before the events of
infinity war so the snap sure hasn't
happened yet they don't know anything
about Dan oh so the black order I'm
guessing that the threat to the world is
twofold one the ghost could just steal
anything she wants from the Avengers
base that's where Tony Stark keeps all
his coolest toys she could do that
anywhere around the world but what they
might also do is try to explain that
when ghost uses her ability it sort of
weakens the fabric of reality because
she's using the power of the quantum
realm to phase through things so those
two different planes of existence
interacting maybe causes some big
problem and that's what the real threat
to the world is because just having a
super criminal around doesn't sound like
a big worldwide threat let me know in
the comments though what do you think
the real threat to the world is through
the ghost character it just sounds like
she's a crazy villain that goes a little
bit nuts when she gets her powers it
just goes around on a tear trying to
steal whatever she wants and then
collateral damage is the weakening of
the fabric of reality but I love the way
that they're trying to misdirect us from
all the Janet Van Dyne stuff like you
remember all the way back to when they
showed off footage at Comic Con they
haven't released it online yet but I
hope that they do because it was Louis
and ant-man explaining the history of
the MCU to Janet Van Dyne because she's
been in the quantum realm this whole
time so she doesn't know about anything
that's happened so that will at least
make the DVD if they don't release it
online I think they're just trying to
avoid showing Janet Van Dyne on screen
because they still want to maintain the
secrecy around the film even though we
all know that she's in the movie now
that we've all seen the end of infinity
war let me know if you're thinking about
the way theists used the gauntlet and
ghost phasing ability because what
happened to banner in the Hulkbuster at
the end of that film Thanos just phased
them right into solid rock and they got
stuck even though there was a bit of a
jump towards the very end of the film
where you just see him standing there
like wait a minute how did he get out of
that the actual end game of this movie
for the ghost character sounds like it
will flow a little bit from that logic
so what happened at the end of the first
am man movie it was all about shrinking
things down so how did he kill the
yellowjacket character he destroyed his
text so he
shrunk down in the most painful way
possible like he was getting sucked into
a really tiny black hole
[Music]
[Applause]
so let me know in the comments do you
also think that the way that they kill
the ghost or get rid of the ghost will
involve a function of her ability like
at the end of infinity war because her
power is phasing do you think they're
just gonna faze her into a solid object
and that's what's gonna kill her
like she'll lose her ability somehow
while she's phasing into something
really hardcore really up in the air
about how WTF the ending of this is
gonna be because Janet Van Dyne seems
like she's gonna be a pretty big part of
the movie and we all have theories about
the post-credits scene because of the
snap shirt and how they're gonna connect
this movie to Avengers 4 because it's
kind of in between even though in the
timeline it takes place before
everything that we just saw I don't
think they want to end on a super downer
moment they want people to be a little
bit happier after the ending is supposed
to infinity war where everybody's still
kind of dealing with the trauma and the
grief mr. stark I don't feel so good I
don't know if they want to end on
exactly a moment like that but I do
think that they want to connect this to
Avengers 4 so I am expecting some small
moment even if one of them doesn't turn
to ash because the thing about
Evangeline Lilly is they said she was
gonna be in Avengers 4 but when she was
talking to interviewers last year she
said that she only shot for about a day
on the Avengers force set so how many
scenes could you film in a single day on
a big movie set like that
not that many so it sounds like ant-man
is gonna be much bigger in Avengers 4
than the wasp is even though it will
feature her somehow
like everybody keeps talking about that
big scene where everyone's standing
together but let me know in the comments
how do you want them to use the wasp
character during Avengers 4 assuming
that she's not going to be a huge
character but she'll be involved in the
plot somehow there'll be a whole bunch
more a man of the wasps dropping really
soon because we're about a month away
for that movie dropping and more Captain
Marvel because they're filming that
again - so leave all your video requests
in the comments below
you don't forget about spider-man -
they'll be filming that really soon so
we'll probably get some more details
about that and maybe a look at what his
new version of the costume is gonna look
like in that film if he doesn't go
straight back to the old version
a costume from homecoming
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Seth Paris please private message
me so I can get your contact details
I'll name a new winner when I post new
marble click here for my new Avengers 4
video and click here to learn about the
new spider-man 2 Jake Gyllenhaal villain
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]